une ferme du manei l'ars arriviez dans
le public mais aussi sur scène ben et
arnaud tsamere ont régalé leurs
spectateurs de leur humour absurde et
partager leur plaisir d'être ensemble
john quelles sont les conséquences du
bric site sur le quotidien des
britanniques ou à tahar ouattar icônes
ci queens of bricks ait fort for the
basic people in the life of all the day
watts
parfois je suis très spectateurs de ben
quand on est sur scène et j'ai envie
j'ai envie de me marrer avec le public
parce qu'il me fait rire il faut un
petit peu lutter aussi contre ça pour
pas que ça devienne juste de potes qui
rit alors tu payes d'une place ou alors
j'ai pas dans le public
du coup c'est de faire du spectacle
crescendo à l'humour de plus en plus
loufoques ben et arnaud tsamere forme
lors du ou en 2013 dans on n'demande
qu'à en rire de la télé à la scène ses
créations leur semblait évidente
je sais pas si les gens s'attendaient
tellement à ce que l'on fasse un truc
ensemble mais nous on avait l'impression
coeur oui on en parlait depuis longtemps
quoi voilà c'était enfin bref c'était
surtout pour nous de dire enfin sur
scène parce qu'on a nous deux c'est
vraiment une envie après avoir fait
beaucoup de sketches à la t&d
disgression de l'improvisation les
artistes font de chaque représentation
une création inédite
ben est un autre sa mère sont en tournée
jusqu'au mois de juin et je pense à tous
ces jeunes du lycée
pour regarder ça on pourra regarder vers
doha